I have a slight elevation in my tumor marker test.
Is that a call for alarm?
It depends on what tumor marker we're talking about.
So let's say, so PSA is a tumor marker for prostate cancer.
And if you still have your prostate,
and you have a slight elevation in your PSA,
no, that's not a call for alarm.
If you have had your prostate surgically removed,
and you have a slight elevation,
then that is a call for alarm,
because your PSA, if you've had your prostate removed,
should be really close to zero.
So usually it's measured as point five or something,
your PSA, and if it jumped up to three,
when you had surgical removal of your prostate,
then that would be, even though it's only a three point,
to a half point jump.
Good to say, that's nothing,
but it is, if you don't have a prostate.
Any of the other tumor markers, the CA9T9,
this CA153, 2729,
common ones would not be a cause of a alarm
if there's a slight elevation.
Now, it is good to look at any blood test over time.
So you're looking at, out of graph,
if you're getting this slow elevation
over the last three years,
it's going in a upward direction on each test.
Of course, that you need to look at that as a cause of a alarm.
Remember, with any blood test,
it's a clue of something that's going on.
You don't treat totally based upon a blood test,
that's certainly not based upon one blood test.
So if there is a giant jump in any blood test,
so this is not even just a tumor marker test,
but if there's a giant jump in any of your markers,
your alkaline phosphatacer, your AST, your ALT,
or your giant jump in white blood cell count,
that's always an indication of something possibly going on.
And you want to take a closer look at that.
But if let's say you have a CA153,
I think the normal is zero to 35,
and let's say it was 42,
and then we did the test again.
It was 48.
Is that a cause for alarm?
No, but you would also look at the possibility to rerun that again,
and test it over time.
So any lab test that you're running,
any marker that you're looking at
is a clue to something going on.
So if you have an elevation or a drop in anything,
you want to investigate possible reasons why,
and there could be a lot of very done,
pathological reasons why things can change.